bon voilà il ya jérémy les bba tactique
attaques qui sont tout content de les
retrouver
il ya là vous voyez souvent y ait
multiplié les quatre fine les pièces
tout ça me disait même où tu plais les
avait fait la multiplication du lait
c'est à dire y avait bien un petit verre
sa vie il a un vrai ya du lait mais cela
il est plus grand que l'autre alors avec
les petits vieux v6 de remplir des
grilles et il est plein 1
même si c'est pas fini c'est vrai
maintenant avec celle ci je vais essayer
de remplir lot parce que l'autre s'il
est encore plus en compte
elle est bien remplie se remplit ceci
est vacillant corde est remplie l'autre
qu'il est plus salée voit remettre là il
est bien rempli
plus la rue cela il avait rempli les
tout grands tours henry gimenez initial
c'est peut-être que ça vous serez pas
surpris parce que vous pensez vous que
tu étais un petit truc dans le vert
c'est ce que vous pensez mais pour
montrer que ces passages que vous passez
maintenant un sens il est rempli tous
les quatre ans qui viennent avec une de
remplir maintenant ils vont se retrouver
a rempli tous les quatre alors s'il vous
plaît vous regarde bien on va voir on
prend le premier le plus mais il remplit
les deuxièmes ça va comme ça comme ça
sent bon les troisièmes sais pas s'il va
essayer parce qu'ils aiment ça et voilà
les ktm on voit si c'est rempli mais il
ya reste encore on arrête tout petit peu
d'art et un peu mes partenaires c'est
très facile mais il faut le faire
[Musique]